[Música]
[Aplausos]
sabíais que en Europa hay un país que a
lo largo de los años ha cambiado tanto
que hasta se ha movido de lugar
sí me habéis escuchado bien y no estoy
exagerando estoy hablando de Polonia el
país que se desplazó al oeste y no de
forma figurada fijaos
Polonia tiene como país una de las
historias más difíciles del siglo 20
invadido y sometido una y otra vez este
país estuvo bajo el control de los
alemanes luego fue invadido por los
rusos más tarde ocupado otra vez por los
nazis Poco después de nuevo los
soviéticos hicieron lo propio Y por
último término siendo un país satélite
de la unión soviética hasta 1989 sin
embargo ahora su suerte parece muy
distinta desde su adhesión a la Unión
Europea en 2004 Polonia ha sido uno de
los países europeos con mejor desempeño
económico su pib se ha disparado en 164%
entre 2004 y 2021 un crecimiento Un 20%
superior al cosechado por la República
Checa durante ese mismo periodo muy
similar al de letonia y tan solo un poco
por detrás del conseguido por Estonia o
lituania dos de los países más exitosos
de Europa en la última década para que
os hagáis una idea Durante este mismo
periodo de tiempo economías como la
española o la Italiana apenas crecieron
un 34 y un 16% respectivamente
Aunque todavía le queda mucho camino
hasta alcanzar a la Europa más
desarrollada Polonia se ha convertido
gracias a su mano de obra relativamente
barata y bien cualificada en toda una
potencia Industrial además sus 38
millones de habitantes le otorgan un
peso demográfico considerable en el
viejo continente por ejemplo Polonia es
el quinto país con más peso en el
parlamento europeo con 52 de los 305
euros parlamentarios lo que le garantiza
en teoría una fuerte voz en el seno de
la Unión Europea
y además ahora como ya os hemos contado
aquí en visualpolitik el país está
construyendo una de las fuerzas armadas
más grandes de todo el continente Así
que teniendo en cuenta todo esto
Cualquiera podría pensar que Polonia
tiene todos los ingredientes para
convertirse en uno de los países más
fuertes influyentes de la Unión Europea
sin embargo stop no vayamos tan deprisa
la realidad no suele ser tan sencilla y
si algo caracteriza hoy por hoy Apolonia
es precisamente estar fuera del
mainstream de Bruselas y queridos amigos
amigas en esta ocasión La pregunta es
muy clara Hasta qué punto puede Polonia
convertirse en toda una potencia europea
en términos geopolíticos Pues bien
veámoslo
[Música]
el chico malo de la clase
amigos amigas la cuestión polaca es
complicada sí durante las últimas
décadas la historia polaca ha sido
fundamentalmente una historia de éxito
sin embargo no todo es de color de rosas
ni mucho menos particularmente con el
actual gobierno del pis el partido ley y
Justicia que ha protagonizado un choque
directo con Bruselas algunas decisiones
como el intento de incrementar el
control del ejecutivo sobre el sistema
judicial o la respuesta dada por ejemplo
a la cuestión lgtb hizo que desde el año
2015 el país fuera condenado
prácticamente a los racismo en la Europa
occidental incluyendo las altas esferas
del club comunitario ahora bien Qué
sucedió en 2015 para que uno de los
casos de éxito europeo se convirtiera a
ojos de Bruselas en una especie de Oveja
Negra Pues digamos que fue el año en el
que el pis llegó al poder
[Música]
el partido ley y Justicia es un partido
perteneciente a la derecha conservadora
con tintes nacionalistas populistas e
incluso algo Euro escéptico Así que
desde el primer minuto su objetivo fue
muy claro Bajo su gobierno Polonia
antepondría los principios tradicionales
y Morales del país a cualquier campaña
narrativa procedente de Bruselas unas
campañas que según denuncian y están
dominadas por una ideología demasiado
sesgada a la izquierda lo que supuso
también poner en cuestión Los lazos con
Alemania una amistad que la anterior
gobierno de Donald task Primer Ministro
de Polonia durante siete años se
preocupó mucho por impulsar
y ojo hemos dicho poner en cuestión la
amistad con Alemania pero lo cierto es
que también podríamos decir
perfectamente congelar romper incluso
Volar por los aires Y además lo
podríamos decir sin el más mínimo
titubeo fijaos no hay duda viendo las
acciones de la Unión Europea que va a
ser un continente bajo hegemonía alemana
Esta es la implementación del cuarto Rey
Martín romanovsky subsecretario de
estado en el Ministerio de Justicia de
Polonia nosotros no encajamos en los
planes germanos rusos para dirigir
Europa un Apolonia independiente
económica y socialmente y fuerte
militarmente es un obstáculo para ellos
desde una perspectiva histórica Esto no
es nada nuevo ya Noki líder del partido
ley y Justicia duros no os parece
Pues bien luego otro momento que
contribuyó a enfriar las relaciones de
Varsovia con Berlín París y Bruselas fue
la tajante negativa polaca de acoger
refugiados durante la crisis migratoria
del 2015 su justificación fue que en
gran medida no se trataba de refugiados
sino de inmigrantes una oposición que le
supuso a Polonia ganarse la imagen de
país insolidario racista e incluso
xenófobo Así que como os podéis imaginar
En aquel momento este país se convirtió
casi en radioactivo en los círculos de
poder europeos nadie quería acercarse a
ellos de hecho muchos analistas
políticos llegaron a calificarlo como
país paria y que supuso en la práctica
todo esto
pues por ejemplo que la Unión Europea
bloqueará la entrega a Polonia de los
36.000 millones de euros de los fondos
Generations de recuperación postkovic
que le corresponden y de hecho así ha
sido hasta que hace poco y gracias al
papel que está jugando Polonia en la
Guerra de Ucrania se ha relajado la
tensión Aunque eso sí no sin muchas
controversias mayo de 2022 la Unión
Europea Esta última dando un acuerdo con
Polonia para el plan de recuperación
covid de 36.000 millones de euros
Bruselas se está acercando un acuerdo
con Polonia para liberar decenas de
miles de millones de euros en
subvenciones y préstamos tras un año de
estancamiento dijo un alto funcionario
de la Unión Europea Julio de 2022
Bruselas cuestiona las reformas
judiciales de Polonia para desbloquear
los fondos de recuperación de la Unión
Europea el primer pago de Polonia de los
fondos de recuperación de la Unión
Europea corre el riesgo de retrasarse
después de que la comisión europea
detectara que faltaba un elemento clave
en las reformas judiciales propuestas
por el país ahora bien esperando un
momento porque no es toda la historia
[Música]
Durante los últimos años y mientras era
una y otra vez amenazar de sancionada
por la Unión Europea Polonia ha
desarrollado un rol regional muy fuerte
y ha liderado alianzas como el grupo de
visegrado o la iniciativa de los tres
mares de la cual Por cierto también os
hemos hablado aquí ya en visualpolitik y
ahora tras la invasión rusa de Ucrania
ha quedado patente que el rol de Polonia
es mucho más importante de lo que nadie
Hubiera pensado atentos
el nuevo paradigma posturania
la historia que comparten Polonia y
Ucrania no siempre ha sido tan buena
como la amistad que los une hoy en día
queréis un dato según las encuestas los
ucranianos eran el segundo pueblo que
menos simpatía les producía los polacos
tan solo por detrás de los rumanos
la relación histórica entre polacos y
ucranianos ha tenido muchos episodios
negros en 1943 y 1944 por ejemplo se
calcula que diversos asesinatos en masa
a manos de partisanos nacionalistas
ucranianos relacionados con Esteban
bandera acabaron con la vida de entre
70.000 y 100.000 polacos en Bolivia la
idea era Limpiaré étnicamente la región
de Galicia del este que hoy en día forma
parte de Ucrania para que nunca jamás
volviera a ser polaca por su parte la
resistencia por la que respondió con el
asesinato de entre 20.000 y 25.000
Aldeanos ucranianos históricamente lo
que más ha molestado a Polonia ha sido
que alguno de los perpetradores de estas
matanzas hayan sido venerados como
Héroes nacionales en Ucrania
y ya sabéis que el siglo fue
terriblemente duro El caso es que tan
recientemente como en 2018 el parlamento
polaco aprobó una ley que declaraba como
ofensa criminal negar los crímenes de
nacionalistas ucranianos ahora bien
esperad un momento porque a pesar de
todo esto las cosas de un tiempo a esta
parte han cambiado radicalmente
[Música]
de hecho Polonia y Ucrania son el vivo
ejemplo de que en muchas ocasiones dar
por zanjadas las rencillas históricas es
la mejor decisión posible hablamos de
dos países que se convirtieron mucho
antes de la invasión rusa de Ucrania en
estrechísimos aliados y ahora por
supuesto los son aún más amigos amigas
Polonia Lleva años guiando a las
autoridades ucranianas sobre qué
reformas hacer y Cómo mejorar su
economía sus instituciones y su sistema
político para adaptarse a un eventual
acceso a la Unión Europea sí digamos que
Polonia se ha convertido en el modelo a
seguir para Ucrania todo esto por no
decir que los inmigrantes ucranianos se
han convertido en la mayor comunidad
extranjera de Apolonia un país que
recordad no es receptor sino emisor de
migración Pero la pregunta que seguros
muchos os habéis hecho es por qué
demonios ahora se llevan tan bien dos
países que durante décadas prácticamente
se han odiado pues lo cierto es que esta
solida Alianza es algo que no solo le
interesa a Ucrania sino que también está
en el centro los intereses estratégicos
de Apolonia y lo es por varios motivos
por un lado para Varsovia salvando
kaliningrado ucranes es una especie de
buffer de zona de seguridad respecto a
Rusia algo que ahora para Varsovia ha
quedado totalmente claro vivamos donde
vivamos en Europa debemos ser
conscientes de que los ucranenos están
defendiendo no solo su independencia y
soberanía sino también Europa entera uti
Nunca se detendrá el expandirá
constantemente su imperio mateus
morabitsky Primer Ministro de Polonia
Asimismo por otro lado Ucrania le
permita Polonia incrementar y mucho su
esfera de poder influencia en toda
Europa y no digamos ya sin un futuro
Ucrania termina formando parte de la
Unión Europea pensad que juntos estos
dos países tendrían más de 80 millones
de habitantes lo que supondría igualar
la población de Alemania y por tanto su
representación en las instituciones
comunitarias además si tenemos en cuenta
a otros países políticamente cercanos a
Polonia como los bálticos o Eslovaquia
Varsovia se convertiría en una de las
capitales más influyentes del viejo
continente Ya sabéis hay que pensar con
perspectiva ahora tras la invasión rusa
de Ucrania es terror y esta ambición de
Polonia ha quedado más clara que nunca
por ejemplo Polonia no solo es el país
que más gastan defensa de todo el este
de Europa sino que además su esfuerzo se
va a multiplicar Durante los próximos
años para convertirse en uno de los
ejércitos más fuertes de todo el viejo
continente Polonia duplicará su gasto
militar mientras la guerra en Ucrania se
recrudece Polonia más que duplicará su
gasto militar el año que viene hasta
138.000 millones de slotti 29.000
millones de dólares además el gobierno
planea gastar hasta 40.000 millones de
slotty 8.560 millones de dólares para
comprar armas en el extranjero Esto es
algo de lo que os hablamos con todo
detalle en un reciente vídeo que os dejo
abajo en la descripción pero la cosa no
va solo de gasto militar
Lo cierto es que durante el conflicto de
Ucrania Polonia ha cogido delantera y se
ha convertido en uno de los grandes
protagonistas políticos en el mayor
receptor de refugiados y uno de los
mayores emisores de ayuda por ejemplo
hasta la fecha más de 5 millones de
ucranianos han pasado por Polonia y más
de dos permanecen allí viviendo desde
que diera comienzo la guerra Además
desde que los rusos lanzaran su campaña
de aniquilación y destrucción hemos
visto a los líderes polacos viajar
constantemente aquí y lanzar un montón
de comunicados y declaraciones en inglés
dirigidas fundamentalmente a la Europa
occidental que se ha movido de forma
mucho más lenta y timorata
el propio gobierno polaco lanzó en abril
de 2022 una campaña internacional para
sacar los colores a los líderes
occidentales de países como Alemania
hablamos de la campaña
detengamos a Rusia ahora que el propio
Primer Ministro por la Cope presentó en
su canal de Twitter una campaña con la
que Polonia estuvo paseando varias
publicitarias móviles por diversas
capitales europeas con eslóganes e
imágenes especialmente duras y críticas
incluso hay un canal de YouTube del
gobierno polaco dedicado específicamente
a denunciar a los líderes europeos por
su tibieza a la hora de ayudar a Ucrania
varsovian ha dudado en liderar la
respuesta europea a Rusia en liderar el
bloque de países del centro y el este de
Europa que apoyan aquí y en presionar al
resto de socios comunitarios en cierta
forma esto ha puesto sobre la mesa el
enorme capital político que Varsovia
Lleva años construyendo Más allá de
Bruselas incluso no ha dudado en echarle
un gélido jarro de agua fría a la fuerte
relación que unía al gobierno polaco
Office con el húngaro y ahora para
muchos líder prorruso Víctor orvan
confirmo las palabras del Primer
Ministro Urban de que los caminos de
Polonia y Hungría han divergido mateus
morabi Primer Ministro de Polonia el 29
de julio de 2022 pero más allá de
Hungría Lo cierto es que Varsovia se ha
convertido en la capital de referencia
del este de Europa Incluso en lo que
respecta al eje Atlántico
una posición que le ha hecho chocar
frontalmente contra los viejos jefes del
club europeo fijaos por ejemplo en las
palabras que pronunció a comienzos de
septiembre del 2020 el presidente
francés Emmanuel macrón unas palabras
que estaban dirigidas como un puñal
directamente contra el gobierno polaco y
también contra los bálticos debemos
hacer todo lo posible por conseguir una
paz negociada no dejar que europase
divida será un desafío diario para todos
nosotros tampoco debemos alinearnos con
los tipos más melicistas que correrían
el riesgo de extender el conflicto y
cerrar las comunicaciones por completo
tampoco deberíamos considerar dejar que
algunos estados europeos en nuestro flan
Oriental actúen solos Emmanuel macron
presidente de Francia hay un abismo cada
vez mayor entre las posiciones de Europa
occidental y las de la Europa oriental
de esta forma por un lado tenemos al eje
Francia Alemania y todos sus grandes
aliados periféricos como España o Italia
que están deseosos de poner fin a la
guerra y negociar con Putin aunque sea
solo para asegurarse el suministro
energético por otro lado tenemos al
bloque Oriental liderado por Varsovia
que defiende armar hasta los dientes a
Ucrania vencer a Rusia romper
completamente con Moscú y reforzar los
datos con Washington y Londres
y ojo que hablamos de una fractura de
una grieta cada vez más grande que
amenaza incluso compartir la Unión
Europea en dos y Varsovia quiere estar
preparada para liderar uno de esos dos
bloques lo quiero hacer desde el punto
de vista político desde el punto de
vista económico como la gran potencial
de la región y también desde el punto de
vista militar Y en este juego Ucrania
puede jugar un papel clave
queridos amigos amigas quizás no seamos
conscientes de ello pero en Europa está
emergiendo una nueva centralidad
paralela a la fijada por Bruselas París
y Berlín un nuevo bloque europeo mucho
más proamericano Pro británico provotan
y composiciones políticas muy alejadas
del mainstream que reina en la actual
Unión Y eso eso es una enorme
oportunidad para que Polonia pueda
convertirse en una de las grandes
potencias políticas del viejo continente
Así que como veis esta guerra ha puesto
sobre la mesa muchas más cosas que la
falta de humanidad y sensatez de
Vladimir Putin la Guerra de Ucrania ha
puesto un jaque Incluso el liderazgo de
París y Berlín y puede terminar
cambiando para siempre la Unión Europea
lo que parece claro es que a la Guerra
de Ucrania le sucederá una nueva guerra
esta vez de carácter diplomático en el
corazón de Europa La pregunta es
terminará Polonia convirtiéndose en una
especie de contrapeso político al tándem
París Berlín dentro de la Unión Europea
Hasta qué punto podría influir el bloque
del este en la política comunitaria
creéis que hay riesgo de que la Unión
Europea tal y como la conocemos pueda
partirse en dos déjanos tus impresiones
en los comentarios y abramos debate Y
por supuesto si este vídeo os ha
resultado interesante No olvides darle
al botón de like y suscribiros a
visualpolitik si aún no lo habéis hecho
muchas gracias por estar ahí un saludo y
hasta la próxima
[Música]